die gängige lehrmeinung sagt ganz klar
aus einzelne kranken sprünge in atomen
sind total unberechenbar und zufällig
doch das spektakuläre experiment eines
us forschungsteams bringt dieses dogma
jetzt gehörig ins wanken
demnach gibt es nämlich vorzeichen die
darauf hindeuten dass ein quantensprung
folgt und nicht nur das wandern sprünge
könnten demnach sogar beeinflussbar und
zu stoppen sein
klinks um science-fiction gibt es
täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen das
gedankenexperiment um schrödingers katze
bringt die annahmen der quantenphysik
ganz gut auf den punkt die katze ist
hier lebendig und tod und das
gleichzeitig auf die kanten welt
übertragen bedeutet dass teilchen sind
in der lage mehrere zustände
gleichzeitig einzunehmen erst das
nachschauen
das messen entscheiden über das
schicksal in diesem fall von
schrödingers katze die in einem
verschlossenen kasten sitz ist sie
lebendig oder tot in der konten für sie
bricht diese überlagerung der teilchen
zusammen sobald gemessen wird erst
dadurch entscheidet sich ob ein
quantensprung stattfindet oder eben
nicht dies geschieht beispielsweise wenn
ein elektron in einem atom auf eine
höheres energieniveau springt dazu der
physiker gerhard rempe nach erwin
schrödingers idee kann ein mikroskopisch
teilchen wie zum beispiel ein atom nicht
gleichzeitig in zwei unterschiedlichen
zuständen befinden
man spricht dann von überlagerung daraus
ergibt sich das beispiel von einer katze
die in abhängigkeit vom zerfall eines
radioaktiven atome zugleich lebendig und
brot sein kann
eine vorstellung die jeglicher
alltagserfahrung widerspricht diesen
sogenannten überladung zustände sind
super spannend für die forschung denn
sie könnten es uns in zukunft
ermöglichen quante netzwerke
aufzuspannen wir haben ja hier schon
öfter bei klicks um science-fiction
darüber berichtet das große problem
solche quantensprünge sind für die
fachleute unvorhersehbar und somit auch
unberechenbar doch jetzt sorgt ein
spektakuläres experiment aus den usa für
aufsehen
demnach gibt es tatsächlich indizien die
auf einen quantensprung
hinweisen und nicht nur dass dieser
könnte sogar noch gestoppt werden wenn
zur richtigen zeit eingeschritten wird
für ihr experiment nutzte das os
forschungsteam einen supraleitenden
schaltkreis ein künstliches atom kann
hier zwischen drei energieniveaus hin
und her wechseln zum einen gibt es den
grundzustand und zum anderen den nächst
höheren zustand auch als dunkler zustand
bezeichnet dieser kann nicht direkt
gemessen werden
der dritte zustand dient zur kontrolle
er wird auch der dritte helle hilfs
zustand genannt wenn das atom dann durch
mikrowellen angeregt wird springt es in
den so genannten hellen zustand durch
das zurückspringen in seinen
grundzustand wird ein photonen
lichtteilchen ausgesendet und genau das
kann durch detektoren registriert werden
die fachleute bedienten sich an einer
kombination aus photonen messung und
mikrowellen daten und kamen dadurch zu
ihrer sensationellen erkenntnis denn
dadurch gelang es ihnen auch den
quantensprung vom grundzustand auf das
sogenannte dunkle energie wie niveau zu
erkennen und das ohne direkte messung
durch diesen trick wurde es dann auch
möglich nach indizien ausschau zu halten
die auf einen bevorstehenden sprung
hindeuten und das mit erfolg denn laut
der studie kann eine photonen stille als
vorzeichen eines quantensprungs
interpretiert werden sprich schon vor
dem ereignis wird der zustand durch
diese stille angekündigt dazu schreibt
das us forschungsziel trotz der
langfristigen und vorhersagbarkeit der
sprünge vom bund zustand in den dunklen
zustand liegt ihnen eine in jedem
durchgang identische phasen der photonen
schnelle voraus die fachleute sprechen
in diesen kontext in diesem zusammenhang
von einer sogenannten no klick periode
die zwei bis zehn mikrosekunden anhält
ihre analyse offenbart auch wenn diese
periode einmal begonnen hat ist ein
quantensprung die zwangsläufige folge
doch das ist nicht alles denn den
fachleuten gelang es sogar einen
bevorstehenden quantensprung wieder
umzukehren und zwar durch eingreifen in
der vorwahl periode wenn sie in ihrem
experiment nämlich ein elektrisches
signal genau zum richtigen zeitpunkt in
den schaltkreis einspeisten fiel das
system in den grundzustand zurück die
studie fasst
folgendermaßen zusammen der ablauf
dieses sprungs ist damit kontinuierlich
kohärent und deterministisch die
deterministische natur des
ununterbrochenen klose kommt für uns
überraschend es ist eine insel der
vorhersagbarkeit in bozen der
unsicherheiten auf den punkt gebracht
bedeutet das also quantensprünge sind
zwar diskrete und zufällige ereignisse
doch die entwicklung des einzelnen
sprungs ist vorhersehbar und verläuft
alles andere als zufällig es gibt also
einen bestimmten zeitlichen ablauf des
quanten sprung aus der sogar einen
eingriff ermöglicht auf das
gedankenexperiment mit schrödingers
katze übertragen heißt das die fachleute
haben die katze mitten im sprung
zwischen leben und tod erwischt und sind
in der lage sie sogar noch aufzuhalten
das ergebnis des experiments ist
wirklich folgenreich für die gesamte
musik und nicht nur das laut der
experten und expertinnen eröffnen diese
neuen erkenntnisse ungeahnte
möglichkeiten denn sie könnten es
ermöglichen kontrollierend in
quantensysteme und deren abläufe
einzugreifen fehler von quantencomputern
könnten so schon im vorfeld aufgespürt
und auch behoben werden denn diese
quantencomputer machen noch umfasst sich
viele fehler
laut der us fachleute vergleichbar mit
dem verhalten wollen von vulkanen dazu
heißt es in der studie
langfristig sind sie völlig
unvorhersehbar aber mit den richtigen
messungen kann man früh zeichen einer
bevorstehenden er zu detektieren und
dann rechtzeitig an nennt ganz abgesehen
davon bringt diese neuen erkenntnisse
die gängige lehrmeinung über
quantenphysik gehörig ins wanken klar
ist die studie ist in der renommierten
fachzeitschrift nature veröffentlicht
und hat damit den so genannten peer
review verfahren standgehalten
dabei beleuchten unabhängige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
studien sehr genau diese dann in
seriösen fachzeitschriften wie science
oder nature beispielsweise publiziert
werden doch höchstwahrscheinlich werden
diese erkenntnisse dennoch für gehörigen
diskussionsstoff in der physik welt
führen dann wird sich zeigen ob das
experiment und seine interpretation
tatsächlich auch auf dauer bestand haben
wäre
quantenkryptographie das geht auch mit
quanten anklicken hier anschauen und bei
xing abonnieren einer meiner absoluten
lieblings kanäle bis dann bleibt dran